and I am sad I didn't know all right we
are live welcome everybody to another
YouTube hangout I'm pumped to be here
with my friend Daniel D Piazza Daniel
welcome aboard man oh hey man thanks or
having me I just found out something
about you that I didn't know and you
just threw it on me like like a bucket
of cold water I didn't like that you're
Canadian oh that that's a bucket of like
amazing water that's that's that's
that's tears from not tears that's like
joy from the heavens water bucket a
bucket of maple syrup there you go nice
that's that's a sticky bucket that
wasn't sticky so Daniels a friend Daniel
has a website rich 20-something he's got
a new book that is dropping on Tuesday
called rich 20-something Daniels built
three different businesses to $100,000
plus in revenue with zero startup
capital so it wasn't just buying his
buying his customers and he's going to
share some of his secrets some of his
strategies to help you guys
entrepreneurs starting up trying to get
some traction with your company oh yeah
Daniel tell us quickly about the book
what's in it what people can expect from
it and then we'll get to questions
coming in from the audience as well well
look ok so first of all I preface this
with saying that we're change we're
changing our company rhetoric now I
don't want anybody else ever again to
say three businesses 200k with no solid
capital because no you don't need you
don't need at least our capital to get
200k I someone took that piece of
language and it's now proliferated to
get across the internet I don't know
where it came from but anyway this is a
good point because in the book I'll
teach you how to get to 100 K without
starve capital it's not hard and the
cool thing about about this book rich
20-something is that really it's like
this it's like this it's like a it's
like one of those black and white
cookies you ever have one those in the
store it's like a black and white cookie
cake an Oreo uh no no it's like it's a
dual sided like half black half white
ever seen those before I've never seen
that I'm Canadian man we don't have half
black half white cookies that's me so
okay so on the other one side it's like
my personal story about how I built
businesses how I overcame a lot of the
mental barriers that I had to wrestle
with coming out of college figuring out
what my what my destiny was going to be
quote
destiny and another half like is the
tactical media strategic side so what's
great about this book is that it's not
just like do this than that manual and
it's not just like a wishy-washy memoir
it's really it's just it's a solid it's
a solid journey through what I had to go
through to start multiple different
isness is where I was learning how to
find clients learning how to show that I
had skills I could provide and
understand in the mental game and then
also the tactical game to like how do
you pick a business that you know is
going to work how do you find something
that you know it learns to me a
marketplace for how do you pitch clients
and find them how do you price yourself
so it's kind of like this really cool
mix of the real world versus like the
tactical world I like it and it comes
out on Tuesday May 2nd yep Tuesday Mesa
I love it so we want to get some
questions in the audience as well but
before doing that we've listed this as
how to start an epic business so give us
give believe nation a couple steps and
what they need to do this start an epic
business I believe nation here's the
first thing you have to make sure that
there is a demand for your business
first because I think one of the biggest
things actually I'm at Fort Bragg right
now and so I'm talking to veterans about
starting businesses and one of the big
things that they have trouble with is
thinking men if I if I leave the
security of either my job with our job
with the army or some sort of like
regular nine-to-five job I don't want to
take the risk of starting a business
because it could fail this is will
probably a lot of people have this
mental barrier if I start it's going to
fail but there are ways to make sure
that it's a good idea before you invest
time or money and waste to an almost
invest no money so here's what I'd
recommend first of all make sure that
that the idea that you want to do is
already being done by someone else
because that will give you at least a
decent amount of foresight into what is
potentially your level of success what I
like to do and I'm just I'm just being
practical with this I like to look at
the things that are already trending and
and find a skill that I can pick start
the business with so I'll go on
somewhere like well now it's called up
work and I'll look at all the different
things they list everything from graphic
design to like video editing to web to
web development to like virtual
assistant and I'll see what types of
jobs are
did and I'll think which of these skills
would I like to learn and I'll see that
there are multiple people asking for
these things or multiple people that are
paying for these services I'll say hey
there might be a business model here and
rather than try to reinvent the wheel
I'll see what people are asking for
first and I'll make sure there's a
market and then I'll go start it because
I know that there's clients in our
market base for it first got it so
that's the first step making sure
there's a there's a solid market for the
next step is making sure that that the
the market actually has the amount of
money that you want to make sure that
you can make some money that you need
and remember that when you're first
starting your business and though this
is this is my philosophy okay everyone
if you're going to if you talk to
tomorrow Zuckerberg has a different
philosophy my philosophy is start with a
service because it's easy and it's quick
so I like to think okay what can I do
now to gradually replace my 95 income so
I look at these jobs let's say we're
going back to the up work example and
I'm finding these skills I'm listing
these things and find someone I can do I
think to myself all right
well I see that these jobs are going for
like maybe five hundred to a thousand
dollars a job maybe I can get a few of
these and doesn't have to be on the up
work platform but it can be you can find
clients out in the wild and I'll say
alright if I can get a few these clients
if I can start to pay for my regular
day-to-day bills with this side hustle
work I can scale it up overtime you
don't need to quit your job in order to
start a new business you can do both at
the same time it starts something on the
side and then once your side income gets
to about sixty to seventy percent of
what's your daily like your monthly
take-home is then you're thinking to
yourself oh well really the only thing
holding back now is the time factor and
since you're still putting time into
your nine to five you can eventually
switch gears and move full-time into
whatever freelance business you pick and
then the third thing I would think about
when starting a new business to make
sure it works is what can you do
differently or better so like let's say
you went on to a job board site to find
what was popular you found something
popular you got a few clients you made a
little bit of money now you want to
differentiate a bit and find something
you can do differently and or better one
of my students micah is a personal
trainer and rather than just be a
standard trainer one thing that he does
is different or better is he goes to
people's houses rather than having them
come to him and he even has like a mmm
fitness man that he wrapped with
stickers so you can see like it's his
face
like flexing on the side of the van he
comes with all his equipment I think
even has like a little workout snacks
for before and after so it's just a
little simple tweak in the service that
makes it completely unique and allows
him to charge more right I like it yeah
cool so people are right in the comments
are liking the value they're taking
notes every step they're taking notes we
are just saying that they have to we
have to get you a black and white cookie
what's with this black and white cookie
Boulder's yeah have you dumped into an
American bakery come on this is this is
a standard thing you go into any
American bakery and you know I've been
the American bakers I've never seen a
black and white cookie I can't speak for
every black and white cookie or every
black and white person all I can say is
that all I can say is that they're
delicious
alright I like it I will test it out
next time I go to an American bakery in
it I'm gonna channel my Daniel and
California cookies um take me take me
through how many chapters in the book uh
there are and this is a sad that I have
to look at my own book to tell you I
think it's ten ten at ten yeah it's a
nice run lover
gimme get just just for like some high
level overview give me the chapter title
and a main thought from that chapter be
quizzing me on my own book judo you know
what I don't even look at it you got it
in front of you captain one is this read
okay just making sure
I really cuz you know it's so funny when
you write something like this I mean I
wrote every single word but afterwards
it's like feel like whoa what do I write
all that that's weird
you know um I just want to get a sense
for what we're gonna get from it okay so
what's in each section so there's ten
chapters like the ten chapters but when
there's ten chapters broken into three
sections right a classical story arc
okay so first section which is the first
few chapters is preparing for the
journey right getting ready to go on
this journey the first part of the book
is all about the mental stuff that you
need to clear out before you can start
the business because again just a simple
example of the barriers about a business
being very risky or or another one we
get a lot is I don't have any ideas I
can't start a business unless I have an
idea the first few chapters of the book
deal with how to overcome these really
common but very pernicious mental
barriers because we know that a lot of
the games we play with our
elves are like weird defense mechanisms
to get us to not to not fail right but
we need to be able to like surpass those
such limitations I mean look at other
people on your on your wall behind you
you know you got jobs the world I know
you have Kanye back there somewhere all
these guys are people who were able to
master their mindset and push past the
fear complex and so we spend a lot of
time talking about how to overcome these
fears and and we also go through a lot
of different scenarios to try to like
completely make some of these fears seem
irrational so we go through different
exercises then it goes seem irrational
and how do how to stop procrastinating
with your stuff so that's the first
thing second thing second phase which is
like the middle chapters of the book we
move into strategy and tactics so what
are the specific ways to start the
business what's my philosophy - so we go
through the freelancing thing we go
through how to scale up from zero to two
to six figures just with a service based
business and then we also talk about how
to move into online world so how to go
from I'm just performing this little
service hey it's Daniel I'm here to like
personal train you - hey it's Daniel now
I'm online and I have a company right
two different things we talked about
that transition and the third phase of
the book is like the kind of the
aftermath and this is a lot of stuff I
had to learn - along the way like okay
you're making a little bit of money now
how do you deal with the with some of
the weird things that come up as
entrepreneur how you stay focused how do
you how do you adjust your mindset to
the fact that you're making a little bit
more money now but you have to really be
your own boss what does that mean and so
the third section talks about that and
it kind of wraps it up I like it cool
well let's get to some questions here
from the live chat you guys have
questions for Daniel leave it there I
know we already got a ton of people
chiming in uh best you Pro are you
familiar with the concept of pulling
from both sides by Gary Vee and what are
your thoughts are you familiar with that
pulling from Gaza I'm not you know that
is Evan I'm not super familiar I want to
I want to say that his clouds and dirt
idea where it's the the clouds is like
the strategy and the big-picture stuff
but then also doing the work library
hustling every day but I don't I don't
want to say that that's necessarily
pulling some flat lines anyway okay if
you give us more clarity on that best
you Pro than maybe I can answer for you
next Praveena how much time should we
spend assessing the demand so back to
what you talked about the beginning
assess demand how do people go about it
you're talking about up work and then
how much time should they spend on that
part yeah so just to be clear I gave
this is this is a very good example for
for interview because it's a very clear
example of how to find ideas but at the
same time up work is a super simple but
only one example of how to find work in
terms of in terms of how to assess the
demand I think a few things have to come
into play first of all just know that
the process of you looking out in the
world and asking yourself is this a
viable business model is part of that
process and if you if you go through
this process another way would be to
look at Yelp reviews or to go on Amazon
it's who people are complaining about
and see where there are pain points as
you go through this process you're going
to become better at assessing what's
real it's a real need of resources
what's a kind of like just noise what's
just switch just static and you might go
through a few iterations of a couple of
business ideas that you think are good
and they seem to have some sort of
relevance and then you start testing
them and no one really wants that and
that would be okay it would be okay if
you didn't hit a homerun on the park the
first time because as an entrepreneur a
lot of this comes down to testing and so
you're building the skill set of
identifying a good idea and that's why a
lot of times when you see really sharp
entrepreneurs men and women who get good
at business they can instantly assess an
idea one of my friends Lori Grenier from
shark tank has this whole concept called
hero or zero and she can instantly tell
you know and I don't know how accurate
she is but she seems to be pretty
accurate she's doing well in the show
she can instantly tell whether business
ideas gonna be good or not and I think
that comes with time and experience so
it's okay if you spend a little bit of
time and it flops or a lot of it time it
does well just find an idea and don't
wait too long to iterate because what
really stops you is the paralysis by
analysis you know spend spend spend a
few days looking it up see if it's a
good fit and then start putting out some
scenes cool so we were talking about
before you're saying making that
transition from a full-time job to your
size hustle making that your full-time
thing and what was the percentage you
gave at 60% 70% 50 to 70 yeah so when
you're making 67
percent of your income from your side
hustle then you quit Neagle full in on
your business yeah I'm getting a
question coming in from from Valley
saying how can I this is great time
management how can I start a business if
I work 12 hours at my job already a day
I mean okay so there's multiple
different ways to think about this the
first way is just like the very
in-your-face garyvee type of like what's
the second shift it's the other seven to
two you know where it's just like you
get home you do your thing with your
family and go back to work there is that
I mean that always is an option but I
think that that can burn you out after a
while so you have to really be able to
assess how important is the business to
you like it is about like working 12
hours a day is a valid thing and you do
have to sleep I get it but at the end of
the day you know if you can put in at
least one to two hours per day and and I
would actually say try to find one block
where you can do that for 30 minute
blocks it's not the same thing as 1/2
hour block so if you can find even one
hour block to get some good work done
once a day that's still seven hours a
week especially on the weekends to
remember the weekends you should be able
to work more than an hour on the
weekends and remember that if you can go
into that one hour block with a plan of
what you're going to do the hour will be
more effective a lot of times it takes
us 30 to 40 minutes just to like clarify
what we need to do so don't go into the
block of time if you only have a little
bit of time don't go into the time with
no plan
spend some time during your work day I'm
sure you have 15 minutes during the work
day to plot out what you're going to do
when you get to your power hour or
whatever you want to call it then go in
there question for an hour and I think 7
to 10 hours a week is not hard to
squeeze out if you really eat got it
that's 40 that's 40 hours a month you
can do something with that yeah I think
- what are you doing doing your job I
think a lot of people take a job that
they're not learning anything weird you
want to if you want to grow like can you
take a job where you're learning some of
the skills you'll need to take into your
business as well or where you have
access to a computer where you can kind
of just like do your own banks types
that's true you know all right I like it
listen to the security guy at my
building likes to overnight of course do
his thing so better be working on a
Shopify store if you're a security guard
all right next up Dion uh how can you
deal with failure and still move forward
into what you want to become so how do
you deal with failure and still move
forward
why is failure um seen as this like
poisonous event why is this a why is
this C I the only problem of failure is
that it's there it's seen as very
negative but what what is the problem
with it I don't understand like let's
let's change the narrative a failure
let's not talk about dealing with
failure let's change our perspective on
on whether failure is bad or not man I
they're a bunch of things I'm feeling
that right now I you can have a book out
about how to charge successful business
and still have trouble in business you
know because as you every time you level
up you have to learn new stuff so you're
going to fail like all the time the only
way that you're not going to fail is if
you don't do anything which is in itself
a failure there's no I mean even you we
could really go meta on you and say that
like the human race is constantly
failing that's why you know we're
constantly trying to evolve and change I
mean so there's nothing wrong with
failure I think that you just need to
learn that that uncomfortable feeling
that you get when you fail something
it's just your ego trying to protect you
but you don't need protection you're
fine just keep going thank you people
are saying love that answer but failure
great answer about failure yeah feel
more yeah I mean but but you know what
let me just urge anyone who's watching
right now it's also be careful of like
the trendy buzz word stuff like hustle
you know authenticity failure like these
become buzz words but I really want you
to take that to heart like outside of
the inspirational stuff really take to
heart what it means to be able to be
resilient and try again there's nothing
there's no personal attachment to you
having some sort of like struggling with
something you struggling with something
isn't an indemnification on your
personal being you having some sort of
like challenge that you're struggling to
overcome doesn't mean that you
personally are a failure this is an
event so I think that if we could all
get a little bit less attached to the
results of things it would wouldn't be
so painful and then we wouldn't be so
scared to try you know
I like it I like it Danya going better
on us so you can go mad at any time man
I like it
let's try keep up with the chat you guys
are going nuts I love it let's see what
else
Valle is asking how important do you
think networking is for an online
business um well there are two things
seems you know networking is obviously
very important but the good thing is
that most people think that oh if I want
that it's kind of the same thing as oh
you have to have money to make money
yes but there's a little asterisk here
so it is really helpful in business to
have already built up a network because
then they can help you but as you go
into business you're going to network
with people naturally as long as you put
yourself out there so I like to think of
especially online business I don't know
about other areas of business but I
think especially online I've I told this
analogy before Evan it's like high
school classes okay depending on what
year you start everyone that starts with
you within like a two to three year
period yeah you guys are in the same
high school class and you guys help each
other because the people who keep going
rise up the ranks and it like we just
had our first book pretty close to each
other you know so like we're in a
similar class I think you have more
followers on one platform a couple files
on another platform we had a book out on
you know similar times we're kind of the
same high school class here now there
are other people who we probably look up
to who are like this juniors and seniors
I feel like I'm a sophomore okay and
they have more followers more traction
they've had more time in the game but
we're networking with each other right
now so don't worry about trying to
always network with like the big guys at
the top because you'll get there
eventually networking people who are on
your level right now who are but who are
doing things and as you guys keep rising
you guys will see that in five years oh
crap
you're both doing good great work and
you've been spend all this time talking
to other all my all my friends who are
we're gonna promote this book I've been
I've known them since day one they're
not new friends you know so start now
but don't worry about the like don't
worry about always shooting for the top
first just do great work where you're at
and then rise to the top with with your
peers I like it I slap that analogy yeah
like I'm not gonna lie like that I'm not
a freshman though I'm not a freshman
anymore
okay Eric once it goes soo
our specific let's see let's see how we
got here Daniel can you please talk
about how to start a tea shop any advice
would be awesome okay um so we're
talking like sip a black consumer will
tea right like I'm assuming I'm assuming
okay so so this is a good one there are
a couple of different ways to do it so
the first thing I think of is you have
to have a unique angle because that
market is I mean all the markets are
kind of flooded so what's your unique
angle I have one of our students who has
a who has a tea company called Jordan
and Jane's and her name is Jordan and
Jane refers to Mary Jane which is like
cannabis infused tea but it's not I
don't think it's psychoactive because
she's in Colorado but I don't think a
psychoactive I think it's more of just
like like hemp tea right but that is a
unique angle because there's a lot of
different health properties associated
with hemp and cannabis so she has a
unique angle where she adds very nice
flavors to it plus there's like the
cannabis angle so I would try to find an
angle if you look online now on
Instagram a lot of these fitness models
are doing doing the skinny tea thing or
like this tea this detox tea cleanse are
you in that world Evan do you know about
that no okay this is a whole world of
girls who want to like get rid of the
tummy bloat so it's called like skinny
tummy tea and they have it in the shaker
and you know I don't know if it works
haven't tried it but apparently you
drink it and it just gets where the
digestive issues and the bloat so that's
an issue that's another type of tea
where you have to have a specific
purpose for if you just gonna make green
tea you know I think Earl's got you
covered like Earl Grey tea is good like
Lipton has got that market so try to go
over something specific in niche so that
you can stand out in a way where even if
you only capture 1% of the market or
half a percent or a quarter percent
they're really enthusiastic quarter
percent you know all right I like it
super tactical got bam-bam-bam
next up hey Daniel hey why are startups
not usually successful is that true
description i you know what i would bet
i'm gonna go meta again here comes okay
well here no here but here's this huge
new train of thought that i've been i've
been playing with and so i'm gonna date
do this on your show Kevin all right I
like it this is a new like a new piece
of thought leadership I've been
developing we need to start asking
better questions because the questions
that we ask create the answers that we
receive and so when you ask a question
like why aren't startup successful
you're going to get a lot of reasons why
they're not successful and you're going
to naturally return these things Maxwell
Maltz wrote a book called psycho psycho
cybernetics where he talks about using
the reticular activation system and I
don't know if this is pseudoscience but
I just remember the terminology
basically the idea is if you think of a
problem backwards you can find the
solution well if you think of a problem
like why don't things work you don't
think of all the reasons what doesn't
work so I would I would challenge you
rather than focusing on that and I'm not
blowing off the answer but I would say
think about why startups do work and
focus on that and just do that the main
reason why they don't work is for a few
reasons one because the founders just
don't want to keep going it's really
hard I think that's the number one
reason they're also there obviously
there are market issues market fit money
you know you can get screwed over by a
partner all these things can happen but
at the end of the day it's really hard
just business is very hard and if you
get lucky in the beginning you're going
to need to build skill to back up that
luck if you have skill in the beginning
you're still going to need some luck to
get you to the top you need skill and
luck and it's and the only way you get
skill and luck is with time so if you
don't put in the time you won't get
those two attributes skill and luck and
you're just going to fall apart so
rather than think about why it's not
going to work find the reasons why
businesses do work and emulate that
don't run from what you don't want run
towards what you do want I like it the
debut oh boom she go in
you should go heavy on that stuff man I
like it boom ah send friend man is
saying Oh Daniel
loved your website you guys can check
out a rich rich 20-something calm I have
a lot of different potential business
ideas can you talk about focusing on and
choosing a single idea to go all-in on
and start your business mm-hmm yeah this
is a good one and you know what's funny
Evan I play this having too many ideas
it's almost more painful than having no
ideas right
because you feel like man all these
could be you look you're watching shark
tank and you're like man all three of
three of those five inventions I've
already had in my head and I haven't
done anything with it taking one idea
out of the three and let's say you have
three ideas I think we all kind of in
the back of our heads know which idea is
usually the best I think we all kind of
know I think that when we have multiple
ideas some of the competing ideas that
we have are things that are like our
passion projects and our fantasies and
some of the ones are that we know are
going to be the ones are going to be the
most successful I would say pick the one
that has the lowest hanging fruit in the
beginning with the lowest startup
capital and the lowest amount of like
inherent risk which is why I always like
a service because if there's if you
don't like the service you can always
quit it there's no inventory there's no
systems to shut down just you and then
also remember that whatever you do now
doesn't have to be the thing that you're
doing next year or in three or five
years you can always start something now
and then you can oh you can still keep
those other ideas and do them later
there's no there's no statute of
limitations or time limit on when you
can do an idea obviously there's the
market changes and people move in and
move out but those ideas are yours like
I still want learn how to play the piano
and I just I don't have time right now
but it's on my list and I will learn
before I die but I'm not you know if I
might not start the next 10 years you
know but that's fine so just keep those
ideas in your back pocket work on one
that seems to be the easiest to get to
right now and then keep going I like it
Deon is saying the more that I'm
listening to this the more I'm being
confident that I will make it thanks
Evan and Daniel oh thanks Evan and Big
Ups to Daniel you should run for office
someday so that's party fun okay this is
also the first time I've ever you get a
lot of exclusives I have a I have a goal
bye-bye-bye 20 years so I guess that
would be 20 well I said by 2042 run for
Senate
yeah because multicast because
millenials will be the politicians at
that time and by then we'll all everyone
who runs for office will have had a long
term public Facebook page there's
nothing we can hide and they're going to
know all my dirty laundry before I run
so I won't have to hide anything so I
can just run as myself
we're breaking news I love it
the year that you heard it here first
yeah seriously I'll talk about that I
like it ah
Oleg wants to know maybe this ties in
Oleg wants to know what is your big
dream a big dream ah
my big dream well you mean right now or
do you mean global like over all right
now my big dream is to is to reduce the
anxiety that this book launch is causing
me uh that's my thing so much it's just
so much so much so much so much so much
but that's a really good question man
you know what I think that my big dream
keeps changing when I was a kid I wanted
to be an FBI agent now that's not one of
my big dreams I am I am NOT tied to the
idea that I have to have one target my
whole life this is a big dream and just
because this this book will have been
published and it's out now doesn't mean
that I don't look at this and really
really cherish having been able to do
this and I always have setting new
dreams I don't have like one I don't
want to be an astronaut I don't have
like one big milestone in my life but I
don't
I also don't think that's a drawback or
to my detriment I think it's I think
it's great to have my like one of my
dreams is for the summer I want to be
shredded is that not good enough I want
to just be jacked you know um I have
little milestone goals milestone dreams
what's your big dream that's what I want
to watch don't talk about my dream
what's your dream Oh flipping it on them
I like it lip in it I like it I like it
cool well it's crazy how quickly time
goes man it's been awesome talking to
you everybody watching when you go to
rich 20-something comm what the book is
just slash book right yeah so choice of
a comm slash book and go check it out
drops on Tuesday Daniel last message of
the day this is it this is your time to
wrap it all up into a nice bow for us to
leave us on a high what do you got man
well I can't leave you quite in a high
because I'm in North Carolina not
California but I will tell you this when
everyone else doubts you when you're
having trouble seeing the end of the
tunnel when you're working harder
something and start working out just got
to believe
you know that's gonna hit with this
audience who's gonna believe that's it
man I love it
guys go check it out we'll link it up in
description to Danielle good luck with
the launch man thanks for judgment I
continue to believe everybody else in
have a good one
please I'm